Israel is at war.
And I'm asking all ministries,
all reborn Christians, to please pray with us.
We here stand with Israel.
And the evil that is working behind
the scenes, stands no chance.
Because God has already overcome this world.
So we are not afraid.
But it is our responsibility
to pray without ceasing.
And these things just show us that we
are getting closer to the end times.
Let's pray for Israel.
There's a lot of innocent
people who are getting hurt, who are dying.
The devil is at work, but God is Lord of Lords.
He is King of Kings, and we should not fear.
He has not given us a spirit of fear, but of
power, of love, and self-control.
So let's pray.